john stockwell is one of our good
friends and a firm fixture on
alternative views I'm sure you know John
by now he was a former CIA high official
for 12 years quit the CIA and wrote very
famous informative book in search of
enemies well he's a full time writer now
Andy is on his novel writing experience
and one is just coming out John what's
the name of it and what's it about well
my second book is red sunset it's a
story about some American oil company
people in a small African capital about
the woman principally and the the
adventure she gets into which includes a
chess match a love story terrorist
kidnap attempt which is the vehicle but
really the purpose of writing the book
was to try to discuss what it's like our
enemies our detractors accuse us of
being imperialists and being involved in
neo colonialism and it's always
fascinated me because I've lived the
life that they call neo-colonialist of
in the big villa in a newly independent
country with several servants and shiny
new cars and jet planes here and there
while most of the people in the country
have very little to survive to live off
of and so this is the story I wanted to
write a story about ordinary Americans
who live that kind of a life and what
what the life is all about and how it
affects the people around them as well
as in so and where does it take place
what are the actual scenes and
characters and actions
I said it in Burundi and I chose Burundi
because it's a very in Africa Burundi is
in chose it because it's exactly in the
center of Africa it's it's as close to
note where it's all so to speak as you
can get it's also very pretty place it's
right on the western Rift Valley right
at the northern tip of Lake Tanganyika
and you have the Mutulu mountains and
the Virunga volcanoes and the Lake
Tanganyika and the city is actually up
over looking alike so it's a gorgeous
little place and as I say quite remote
well you grew up in and well I grew up
in Zaire which is right across the
other side of the lake and then I served
in Zaire with the CIA these mutant low
mountains that are right about in this
book were Haven of rebels when I was in
Zaire but I also served in Burundi at
one time so we had problems with the
mountains were sort of an intelligence
target so we were covering them I was
sending people into the mountains and I
became fascinated with them in fact
there were no viable rebels there are
there was a great exaggeration of the
rebel threat because that's a good way
to keep the United States and its aid
interested in in supporting your country
and I try to bring this out there was a
kidnapped threat that was brought to us
from people across the lake who came
into Burundi and said that they had
information of a plot to kidnap the
American ambassador and this of course
stirred us up no wind as you can imagine
flash cables to Washington and on a
full-time alert and every security
measure we could take it turned out it
was just a con it was just some guys who
wanted to squeeze a little money a
couple hundred dollars out of us but
then I was there in 70 71 about when I
left but in 75 these same people did
kidnap for European scholars working
with a Cal Tech grant who were studying
fish or something on the lake and they
did kidnap them and take them into the
mountains and so naturally writing a
novel about that area I wanted to
incorporate how you know how a kidnap
plot could work and what kind of people
would do it and how it would affect the
people in the city itself mostly focus
on the African political situation or
the sort of match nations between
America and the Soviet Union behind the
scenes or do both of these themes come
out those those themes are in the
background I wanted to focus on the life
of an American woman who finds herself
in such a place and there is a Soviet
diplomat involved there's a she plays a
big chess match against the local chess
master who's a South African banker and
some of their friends are British
and the Africans are in the background
their subplot sort of in the background
which some of the reviewers have said is
in a way an ironic way the strongest
part of the book is the Africans in the
background but I really wanted the story
to be about this young woman not about
politics of diplomacy so much as just
her life so there's an element of the
love story and that as well as a
political novel you're trying to combine
these things it started out to be more
of a political intrigue novel adventure
intrigue and real-life politics and what
happened was the love story took over
the book it was a subplot originally and
then by the time I got the manuscript in
New York and sold it the editors wanted
me to focus on the woman and a love
story and essentially they persuaded me
and so it is primarily a love story well
John you've been prohibited by the
courts now to say anything or write
anything about the CIA and its
operations no no that's not exactly
correct no I can say all kinds of things
about the CIA but I have to submit it to
them for censorship first so I assure
you I could write a hundred thousand
page book about the CIA and as long as
it was favorable they wouldn't finish
their words but you can speak though
well impromptu speaking is covered
particularly if it's about the subject
of my previous book or what I've
lectured before they they admitted that
it would be very difficult to try to
enforce an injunction against interviews
and speeches but if I had written notes
for say this interview I would have to
submit those notes for censorship
well we long as it's impromptu though
I'm supposed to be okay we have a lot of
things here loaded up about the CIA the
stories and information that we've been
gathering waiting for your next trip
over the alternative views fortunately I
haven't seen their notes that they're
going to be working from and they're not
under injunctions they don't have to be
censored delegate that you have probably
the most important one that well John to
start off let's look at the CIA under
the Reagan administration what are some
of the most significant
Frances visa via the CIA under Reagan
what is he done in terms of his policies
have affected the CIA well the the
Reagan election when he came into office
there was great joy in dancing in the
hall for the CIA they recognized that
they would be set back into full full
fledged activities much like they were
at the height of their powers in the 50s
and 60s and and that euphoria has pretty
much continued I have not been inside
the building obviously but I have had a
couple of conversations with people who
were and without telling me anything of
any substance they did their voices were
were crowing and gloating about how the
world was being righted in their mind
and they were out there defending
national security and freedom in all
kinds of places as the CI has done in
Chile and Angola and Nicaragua elsewhere
for so many years the nads on October
the 1st that they're going to literally
double the size of their new
headquarters the CIA which would
indicate that they're obviously planning
many more activities and an expansion of
their entire operations what are some of
the evidence of an expanded CIA under
Reagan well of course you know I was
kidding I was up in Washington recently
and I was getting so many invitations to
go in lecture that I was I was kidding
and saying that I had something that
would go on forever because I'm the last
whistleblower because they've got the
court orders and injunctions and the
Supreme Court rulings and now the names
of agents bill going through and there
won't be all of which is to say that we
probably will never know for sure what
they're doing now under Reagan because
they are succeeding in getting in a de
facto Official Secrets Act so the
American public and the victims will
never know the true stories of the
current activities like the war in
Goler the previa tom CIA covert action
the chile coup the assassinations they
will be muzzled probably forever so we
won't know for sure what you hear about
are the occasion it's an organization
that will always go around shooting
itself in the foot because it deals with
activists who are trained to to break
the law who have activist instincts and
they will always be getting themselves
in trouble and what we're really seeing
now are gross blunders and gross
missteps and one case where two agents
went so far afoul of propriety in the
law that it did erupt into the public
view that's terpil and wilson purple
arrow on 60 minutes and a PBS
documentary whether those are the ones
who helped we're helping libya right
incredible if if you can believe it at a
good day i hope look at the way our
president is dealing with the libyan
problem and Qaddafi our country's so
concerned with the terrorism the hitman
team that was supposed to be tracking
our president down to killing and now we
find that two fairly senior CI officers
were out actually training they had read
they had resigned from the CIA but they
were being supported by people who were
at the very top of the CIA who it's not
clear and of course it may never come
clear exactly to what degree they were
being supported but they were being met
debriefed and assisted in some ways by
people like Ted Shackley who is a top CI
he was chief of the Latin America
division chief of the Far East division
and then assistant deputy director of
operations now what were these men doing
they were making millions of dollars
selling CI terrorist equipment expertise
and actually training Libyans selling
this equipment to Libya and actually
training terrorists in the Libyan China
like terrorist training camp
now as the story is being squeezed out
in bits and pieces it's coming out it's
now been documented that
there were active-duty Special Forces
officers helping them to Train
terrorists inside Libya now we're
talking about up until 78 79 and there
are also CIA active duty personnel at
China Lake training terrorists and it
this even boggles my mind having been
inside and and from what I've seen but
all of the all of the to do were making
about terrorism and here we are
delivered here our CIA is delivering
technology and actually training Libyan
terrorists this sort of illustrates your
thesis in search for enemies that the
function of the CIA is to cause problems
that makes it possible for military
intervention so that would fit into this
sort of scenario that you've drawn
indeed and there's no other real
explanation for it now one one of the
CIA officers who was still in the CIA he
denied at first association with him
they were claiming that he had support
him he denied it and then when it when
it was when he had to admit or perjure
himself he had to admit that there was
association he he claimed that it was
only to keep contact so they could tell
him what to who the terrorists were and
what they were doing therefore it was a
legit legitimate CIA enterprise but then
when the Senate tried to squeeze out and
the Justice Department documentation
from the CIA there was none
and he said that was because it was
something that he was keeping in his
vest pocket so either we have a
full-fledged CIA operation or we have an
illegal venal corrupt operation but
either way there was complicity with
these people who were training and
making the Libyan terrorists a great
deal more more effective now mind you
we're talking about millions of dollars
we're talking about the the latest and
terrorists you know explosive devices
and and the way you can make an ashtray
into an explosive device so when a bad
guy puts out his are good guy for that
matter puts out his cigar it blows up
and kills everyone in the room
for a fact well isn't there that this
seems even more incredible from a couple
points of view one is the fact that
maybe it's a super Machiavelli n'they
that the CIA and the FBI need to have
terrorists in the world to justify their
increased money for appropriations for
instance when the CIA made their latest
report they indicated that there were
thirty three hundred and thirty six
terrorist attacks during the previous
year now Alexander Haig didn't think
that was enough so he sent the report
back to the CIA say give me more
terrorist attack so they they upped it
to almost six thousand this then the
other aspect of this is that the CIA has
historically had a close relationship
with the Israeli secret police the
Mossad and yet the Mossad and the Libyan
government and their secret police or
mortal enemies supposedly so what's
going on here well on the one hand the
CIA purist would argue that we have an
intelligence requirement to provide
information to our government about
terrorists and terrorist organizations
about the world and therefore the only
way you can get this information is to
penetrate terrorist organizations get
your people inside so they can tell you
what's being done the other side of that
is is very much in the direct and on the
first argument you would you would try
to have contact with Mossad and with the
Libyans and with the PLO and with the
red brigade anyone you could and the KGB
and a KGB to to gather information about
them that's the purest purest argument
but how can you explain this provision
of of shiploads of terrorists equipment
to the Libyans and training by
active-duty Special Forces and active
duty CIA officers that that's where it
gets some Machiavellian it blows your
mind and there's no way you can justify
delivering the equipment to them in
order to gather information about who
they are that's not necessary to gather
intelligence and the only answer is that
a little bit of both that you have an
organization that functions in a
troubled world it gets more money and
more opportunity as like you say Hague
wants 6000 terrorist bombings last year
not 3,000 because it's more dramatic and
he can get more mileage out of at the
CIA by the same token would like to have
a more troubled world because there they
have more to do the president in the
Congress and the press and everybody are
relying on them and giving them their
carte blanche more in a troubled world
and in a peaceful world but then the
other thing that has raised its head not
the first time but but so ominously in
this Wilson terpil thing is is
individuals doing it for gain for
millions of bucks let's face it someone
in the CIA's comanded wars around the
world it sent people off to die which
you know which is the ultimate ego trip
for a pentagon type of person is the
ultimate power that a human being can
have is to send other humans off to die
not the sentence one individual to the
gas chamber but send 5,000 off to die
well take someone who's been at the top
of the CI and he's been doing this
secretly and and commanding forces in
the world manipulating governments and
then he hits a certain age of maybe 50
or possibly 60 if he goes the whole
route and then he retires on 20,000 a
year and it just you know it just isn't
comfortable it doesn't work now some of
these people have managed to retire
comfortably like Bill Colby the former
director and dick Helms former director
by becoming agents of foreign
governments and so declaring themselves
to our Justice Department and getting a
salary from the Iranian government or
the Japanese government or elsewhere and
people down the line have done the same
sort of thing Walter's is now driven
west hundreds of thousands of dollars
consulting for Guatemala
Argentina Chile etcetera and Vernon
Walters is who the deputy director of
the CIA when I was in he was the deputy
director over me and was Nixon's White
House man too so selling themselves as
agents of foreign governments to sell
their expertise in contacts that they
gathered in their CI
and then you have these guys it's now
surfaced and it's it's an obvious it's a
documented fact have been selling
technology tourist technology to the
Libyan government meanwhile our
government is not moving against the
Vernon Walters or the DES councils or
the bill Colby's who have become agents
of foreign governments but they're suing
john stockwell for writing a book to the
american people to tell the truth about
what's going on and they're trying to
pass a bill that would make it illegal
for any publication to publish the names
of any CIA agents how does this
constitute threat to freedom of the
president mind you this bill is it's
justified on the basis of the revelation
of names but the bill goes far far
beyond names it says names of secret
agents or the activities of secret
agents that could draw attention to them
now this means for example let's take
some things that the CIA has done a
secret agent kicks in your door and
rapes your wife now if you went out and
wrote an article about that and
published it in the paper both you and
the editors of the paper even if you
didn't main you just said Mr X working
for the CIA kicked in my door last night
and raped my wife that would be a felony
under this law and a debate in Congress
on this law some of the critics and
there are some fortunately but not
enough said wait a minute
the way this thing the way I read this
proposed bill if the London Times
published an article about a CIA
escapade somewhere the New York Times
could not reprint the London Times
article without committing a felony and
the sponsors of the bill stood up and
roared that is right we want to stop all
of this talk about the CIA so what we
have here by the sponsors own admission
is an official secrets act and a very
strict one one that will cover anything
they want to cover up they classify it
and claim it has to do with secret
agents activities my book can never be
published the the CBS and PBS
that you mentioned on on terpil and
Wilson could not be published it would
be a felony many of the 60 Minutes shows
would be felonies so this provides a
cover of secrecy for the CIO of the
broadest possible sort for the first
time in our history freedom of speech
has been is being it hasn't passed yet
although the nose count is that it will
go sliding right through Congress right
now but for the first time in our
history the secret police of the
government are being given legal
precedent over freedom of speech and
freedom of the press now mind you
they've bludgeoned people before and
punished people before such as myself
and Frank snap and and Phil Agee and
Marchetti for for attacking for
criticizing the the CIA but they've done
that in civil court but now it will be a
felony to criticize the CI to complain
about its activities to expose its
corruption and and the record is clear
we're talking about an organization that
has been responsible for 300,000 deaths
by their own records by the Senate's own
records 300,000 deaths in it in the
third world and that's that's a modest
figure I gave that figure myself in
Senate testimony and the next morning sy
Hersh I was playing tennis with him and
he he he said Stockwell you're all wet
he said the figures over 500,000 you
forgot Indonesia now that's what they've
been doing out in the world of course in
the mood of these times there are a lot
of Americans who who would just assume
melt Africa or Asia or wherever they
really could care less but they have
been doing things in the United States
that you would you know Strangelove the
kind of things that you would only
accredit to the Gestapo or the KGB if
they're worse all in drug control mine
MKULTRA extensive over years
experimenting with unwitting Americans
by by dropping them LSD and then filming
their activities under the influence of
drugs they didn't know they had received
as well as infiltrating political groups
and spying on Americans which were
against the CIA Charter it was not
supposed to go the
medically involved and Carter put some
guidelines regulating domestic activity
the CIA and Reagan signed an executive
order putting these aside putting these
assigning effect unleashing the CIA
domestically so that any political group
can be or any individual could be the
target of the CIA operation so this is a
another threat to our civil liberties
here and they come for sure and they're
defining who the targets are they don't
have to even go to a judge and say we
think this person is a target they
decide to a target is and secrecy as
I've said before and and many other
people have said including some some
leading senators secrecy is primarily
designed to cover up their misdeeds only
in the very rare most internal sensitive
cases is secrecy a matter of national
security yes diplomacy at a certain
point you need some secrecy to negotiate
some things at a certain point some
military operations have to be secret to
work but you know we're talking about a
tenth of a percent as compared to
everything that is in fact being
declared secret what they're trying to
cover up is the wars the killings the
drug experimentation and the corruption
there's another bizarre development that
seems to be taking place with the CIA
under the Reagan administration that I
think involves a tremendous expansion of
CIA operations and a sort of new field
for the CIA to get involved in and
that's the use of businessmen and the
Department of Commerce as potential
agents when the max Huell affair took
place early in the Reagan administration
where this corrupt politician
businessman friend of Reagan's was put
in a position of high power in the CIA
and it turns out that he had all kinds
of corrupt business backgrounds and
connections it came out on abc's
nightline the Ted Koppel show in an
interview with Bobby Inman whose deputy
director of the CIA that the reason Matt
Hyuga was brought into the White House
was that he had a lot of businessmen
connections that they would be able to
use for operations abroad what do you
make of this is this significantly new
field for the CIA to be
well then we know that they've used
politicians and diplomats abroad they've
used military abroad they've even used
journalists that's been revealed well
it's by no means new but but we're
talking about a degree they've done it
many many times and they've done favors
for people all over the world gathering
information for them you know a little
favor yes we'll find out this for you
what not but it's a question of degree
and in in the last few years including
before I got out there was the
government the US government was crying
for more economic information and during
a lot of the years that I was in we were
not you know we would get an economic
information and pass it on to the
ambassador to stop him in the hole and
say hey I heard such and so a deal is
going down or something but what's
happening now Michael is my microphone
is falling off the CIA image and I'm
sure yeah what's happening now is that
this corruption that I'm talking about
where a political party a White House
administration is salting people into
top positions in the agency because of
their business connections with the
intent of using the organization and its
resources to gather intelligence to help
the people who are sponsoring that party
this is of course the heaviest form of
corruption that position that hugo was
in was deputy director of operations now
this is the focal point the commanding
officer of worldwide clandestine
operations now you think of the
sensitivity and the complexity of covert
operations in 150 countries and this is
a job that has to be a pro and a
brilliant pro and one with driving
energy in any sense of the word I mind
you I I think that we would probably be
better off achill job didn't exist but
but there's no way it can function with
a political appointee in there and as a
matter of fact there was a part of the
reason he was withdrawn was because he
was shooting himself in the foot
repeatedly several times there was an
incident about Libya and he was
in this effort to get the CI moving
again he was approving some some
exceedingly dangerous operation
assassinating Qaddafi according to a
Newsweek he was proposing to assassinate
Qaddafi and there to my relief now the
Senate Supervisory the Oversight
Committee which has never succeeded in
overseeing the CIA room I never tried
very much mostly they're encouraging
them to go out and do they did scream at
that one and stop him and it was shortly
thereafter that hugo was was removed
from office now we have the other one at
the top William Casey is another
businessman with all kinds of conflicts
of interest he's still holding the
portfolio on his own business interest
plus all of his contacts and he's
running the whole intelligence
organization right now and he again like
the other one he's shooting himself in
the foot about once a week and late
lately
two days ago he testified to the Senate
and about the freedom of information
operation and he was claiming that the
CI couldn't function because they had
had so many agents wouldn't work with us
but also so many people resign because
of this foi a and when the committee of
course didn't just take his word for it
they said give us documentation and he
couldn't produce any documentation and
finally he had to admit that not one
person had been fired because of her
resign because of the foi
so once again john you were talking
about complexity and byzantine nature of
some of the operations it goes on and
the and the CIA here is one really
mind-blowing thing which was in the
August 81 inquiry the libertarian
magazine it talks about an incredible
thing it talks about first of all a
florida-based worldwide Finance
Corporation that's that's its name it's
a financial conglomerate and after there
were some complaints that led to the
doorstep of this thing a local district
attorney started investigating it there
were congressional investigations and
the Justice Department started getting
into it and they found that CIA was
involved
Cuban exiles were involved which isn't
really all that unusual because they've
been involved for decades down there in
the Miami area
okay they'd the water in their
operations against Fidel Castro nation
of a president right but this also gets
involved with drug trafficking and even
further than that they found that there
are relationships with the Russian KGB
and the CIA operating together
exchanging information they found that
there is root their men relationships
with Castro's intelligence and the CIA
in which the CIA and Castro decided that
they would permit the drug trafficking
and helping it along and then share the
the help and sharing and the profit so
they could so they could finance each
other's operations and it the
investigations well they kind of became
so complex that the investigations not
only kind of collapsed because they
couldn't figure out what the heck was
happening they couldn't unravel it but
also the CIA stepped in put the kibosh
on it and even the FBI was frustrated
because they were involved in a - this
seems like something which you couldn't
even dream up if you had a wild
imagination we were on some kind of drug
trip does this sound unreasonable no
yeah you know like real life is often
stranger than fiction and I've already
run into this in the three books that
I've written with trying to write scenes
is exactly as they happened and then
your editors scream edge and you say but
but I was there and that's exactly the
way it happened and they finally say
well nobody would believe it in print
but yes I'm quite sure that's that could
happen I don't know anything about that
organization I haven't followed it but
all of that could easily happen
well they one part of it really sounds
true and that's the permission and
expediting of the narcotic traffic for
the Cuban exile so that they can help
finance their operations this sounds
very much like what was going on
in Vietnam Southeast Asia sounds like a
dream business to get into because you
would be able to do favors for the CIA
the FBI the KGB the anti-castro groups
in Florida and the an Castro himself and
the drug runners so you would have all
of these organizations paying you off
and giving you protection and that
sounds like if you were if you were into
corruption in crime it would be a dream
organization well there was drug
trafficking by the CIA and during the
Vietnam War yes that has been documented
and the work has been politics of heroin
in Southeast Asia with with documents I
mean documented with government
documents they got that conclusively
proved and stated that the CIA was the
way it started is they were working with
mountain yards who had up in Thailand
mostly Berlin Laos Cambodia and Vietnam
who had made their living traditionally
by growing heroin and shipping it out
and so they had the CI had its Air
Forces flying planes back and forth and
Moulton Yard allies would be flying down
to the Capitol and they would want to
get on the planes of these suitcases
full of heroin and the CI you know some
CI officers were trying to kick them off
with Jinnah these really needed them so
the CIA was making decisions to let them
ride and then it got to the point where
and by that I'm making making decisions
up the chain of command then it got to
the point where they were actually
flying special flights dc-3 flights to
carry the the heroin down to the Capitol
as favors for the Allies and also to
sort of help finance the whole operation
and then it got to the point where of
course some of the CI officers involved
were finding ways to use CI vehicles to
fly this stuff back to the states and
market it let's document it John now the
last leg of that was not to my knowledge
approved by Washington that was that was
the maverick but the rest of it was
proved by Washington there's another
surprising story that came out in the
latest covert action information
bulletin and that is that shortly before
his death Anwar Sadat admitted
that Egypt was the conduit for CIA funds
to create problems in Afghanistan to aid
the rebels so that the United States was
involved early on in the Reagan
administration with actually fostering
the Afghan rebellion have you heard any
stories of this nature only what I've
read in the press and you know this gets
this to me gets into some of the
ultimate cynicism at the same time one
of more complex decisions of people in
the intelligence world is you have the
Soviets in Afghanistan and it's our
national policy policy to regret their
presence there you have rebels who are
fighting them and obviously if they had
more arms they would fight better but
there isn't any chance of our giving
them enough support that they could win
or even get some momentum going against
the Soviets
so we trickle some arms into them so
they can escalate the flight the
fighting with the result that a lot more
people are killed and their hopes are
raised and they thank their in some
cases they're flat told of course the
worst case in history of this being done
was where the CIA had a huge program to
encourage the Hungarian Uprising and
they succeeded the country erupted in a
massive uprising and then when the
Soviets put their tanks in the United
States jumped you know back across the
ocean and got our hands off the place
and the Hungarians 20,000 Hungarians
died what happened with the Kurds yeah
percent for the Kurds a similar occurred
yes Ron yes many thousands of Kurds died
identical when we had satisfied the
Shahs little pressure policy initiative
against Iraq and the Shah said okay I've
got my agreement with Iraq we jumped
back and withdrew our aid from the Kurds
and the Iraqis retaliated and wiped them
out there was also a report here about
biological warfare in Cuba that certain
mosquitoes were introduced the Cubans
claimed by the CIA that resulted in
fever malaria of all sorts if you heard
anything about that story yes the dingy
fever I've certainly heard about it I
have seen written stories about it
I've talked to people about it the the
us health the us medical authorities
line is that it's not technically
possible to introduce fever or fever
ridden mosquitoes into Cuba which is of
course nonsense the difficult things
about that is that there's an epidemic
of fever in Cuba
the Cubans claim the CIA was behind it
if the Cubans could be making it up they
could believe it and be saying it or it
could be completely true the point
though is that our government our CIA
has been guilty of so many things just
as nasty is that over the past thirty
years that it's absolutely impossible to
deny it plus the fact that they carried
out experiments just on this type of
thing they've exactly millions of
mosquitoes over at Charleston South
Carolina to just to observe what would
happen and then apparently who it's
possible then they put this into effect
in Cuba although it then I understand
their main their main target would have
been for Soviet Union well they're
preparing for the biological warfare
wherever you know in our concern with
nuclear warfare and I am very concerned
all these atom bombs that we have and
they have and the macho people some of
them not very great being themselves on
the other chest and talking but the
chemical and biological bombs that are
being amassed maybe a hundred times as
lethal and dangerous and threatening to
life on Earth than than the nuclear bomb
well the Nazis foresaw this rather than
put their technology into a nuclear
atomic bomb program they had these
chemical warfare do you remember the CIA
had had been it had been revealed that
they had some poison they were and and
the President Nixon had ordered them to
get rid of it and then they didn't get
rid of it and President
and director Colby was called up to
explain why they hadn't obeyed a
specific presidential order and with his
incredible talent for disarming the
Senate he said after all gentlemen we're
not talking about a big warehouse he
said we're talking about something this
size and he held up a little vial it was
enough poison to kill everyone in a city
of 50,000 he held up a little vial this
big he said it was sitting in the back
of a safe and you know when you think
about that and when you think that there
are warehouses of that poison alone not
to mention the disease and germs and
things that can blow this way and that
the word and there isn't the the
publicity of the public attention on the
the ABC of Arsenal's that are being
stockpiled John another event we wanted
you to comment on since this is part of
your past experience in South Africa
Angola has to do with the invasion by
South African troops in Angola on the
pretext that Angola is supporting men
being rebels and that South Africa has
to clean up the operations there and
there's Soviet and Cuban troops there
their threat to South Africa would you
comment on that puts the current status
has South Africa been continuing to
harass and go a several months back we
reported in detail well it's my
understanding that the South African has
sort of a permanent military force
inside Angola I don't mean they built
camps but they are they're bombing
raiding dropping people in or cuddling
up on a permanent basis regularly
several hundred miles up inside Angola
what you have in terms of the validity
of their claims you know Africa was was
when it was broken into colonies that
became countries they were done without
any reference whatsoever to the the
existing tribes or ethnic groupings so
that in Angola for example you have on
the North you have the buck Congo as a
large original tribe that now overlaps
in three countries and in the north
yeast you have the balloon de whoo
overlapping ghola and enters a year and
in the South you have the people who are
the Namibians are the people who are of
the ethnic grouping with the people in
South West Africa but half of the people
live inside Angola
now it goes without saying that these
people with their ethnic link to those
people are going to be sympathetic and
it's going to be support and it's going
to be traveling back and forth across
the border but what you get into is of
course modern law what is South Africa's
right to go up and bomb and strafe South
Africa's position of course is is it's
an outlaw position on Southwest Africa
they're simply refusing to give it its
own freedom its own elections it was
mandated by the United Nations a long
years ago and they've just absolutely
refused to cooperate with this and to
date no pressure has been brought on
them that would really encourage them to
de cette nobody be afraid to give it its
free elections is there any evidence of
CIA complicity and as Frank wanted to
ask about the Seychelle Islands some of
these might be connected well there was
a coup attempt of the Seychelles Islands
in which a rugby team supposedly rugby
team came into the Sahel Islands into
the airport there are also some people
that were that came in earlier in hotels
and they tried to overthrow the
government they had weapons with them
and later it was determined that they
their base of operations was South
Africa and matter of fact they took over
an airplane returned to South Africa
from what you're reading this is is
there was there CIA complicity and money
involved in that or the South Africans
just becoming like a new CIA and doing
the realm engine well it also connected
and in all in all fairness and state the
obvious the CIA is not the only agent of
mischief in the world
and there are many other agents of
mischief
the CIA is working with many of the
others as they do as they commit their
crimes I have as far as is there any
documentation I wouldn't have the
faintest idea all I know is what I've
read in the papers so you have to
speculate they obviously had at least an
atmosphere of encouragement in South
Africa including in the South African
government when they sky jacked the
plane and flew back to South Africa five
of them were arrested and the rest were
just turned free immediately in these
five were flown off in a helicopter to
someone's estate after posting a minimal
bond then because of international
pressure South Africa did go back and
arrest 30 more it's not clear yet what
they're going to succeed and what
they're going to try them for or if they
will in fact convict them but I could
easily see something like that as more
likely developing from South Africans
with they're very aggressive attitude
towards the Seychelles possibly with CIA
foreknowledge but quite possibly without
the CIA knowing about it ahead of time
had the CIA known about it ahead of time
I'm reasonably sure they would not have
complained it protested that wouldn't be
in their nature but I see no reason to
to suggest that they set it up on the
other hand it's quite possible it's the
sort of thing that the CIA station chief
might very well do having dinner going
to the office of the boss chief I think
they call it something else now the
South African security force and saying
you know what you know you big talk what
are you going to do about the Seychelles
why don't you fly some people up there
and take the place and turn it in the
right direction and then the South
African calling in a couple of rugby
players or former mercenaries and saying
you know it would be easy here's what
you would have to do and giving them
some advice and guiding and setting it
in motion maybe some money I might note
to our audience it is quite remarkable
the giant star
in the last few years has begun this
second career as a novelist as you might
know it's very difficult to get a book
published much less a novel these days
and John's first novel was immediately
picked up by William Law which is one of
the best New York publishers and has
just come out so we congratulate you
John and your new career and wish you
all the best but we still want you to
come back and talk to us about the CIA
and many other things on our alternative
views remember I'm the last
whistleblower I'll never never be dated
thank you John thank you thank you very
much